[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
we talk about whatever we want baby
we got dante back hey
and speaking of off the record so like
we before we rolled the cameras
it's crazy how like all of us as like
millennials
we have a shared childhood i'm a gen xer
by the way
you are yeah yeah but you know you are a
part of the millennial
uh childhood yeah yeah yeah yeah you're
one of us because the millennials were
watching
like like the gen z know you as zuko
right but then like millennials know you
as uh rufio
right but like so like past gen z
and then now that you see like mega
stars was probably our generation like
michael jackson michael jordan whatever
where like the whole
united states knew like this pop culture
and it was one pop culture
but now i feel like there's hella
different
pockets subculture yeah so like there's
like
kids that are like hella into kpop and
then they know all about this or anime
or like youtubers and then there's like
little
empires like the like people that are
like fans of logan paul or whatever
right
it's the internet the internet changed
the world because before the internet it
was just the big businesses and studios
and stuff feeding us
and the record companies going this is
what it is yeah yeah this is the new hot
[ __ ] this is you're a new host you
should have a shared
thing maybe like playing minecraft or
like something but they don't have like
a shared
everybody knows this one person of this
new generation kim kardashian no you
might know
certain things but you might not even
know like you can hear kim kardashian
it's like pokemon like i know pokemon
but do you know all the cards
do you think that's part of the reason
why we're so separated like you know
because back in the day regardless if we
had
views that we agree with each other we
could be completely opposite
politically religiously whatever right
but we all saw hook yes
and then we all saw or like you know
michael jordan is just the greatest no
matter what
but in this day and age it's not only
are we do we have different opinions on
things
we also i have a different michael
jordan than you do so everything is
different there's no
that's a good point no spying that ties
the whole country together yes
or the whole world the whole world yeah
the whole world then back in the day it
was like
just the movie industry you had to go to
the theater to actually see the movies
or sometimes get the bhs or whatever
but also like in the radio like that's
how we all got our music
is from the radio but now it's like
streaming
everyone i'll tell you how crazy it was
back in the day it was like so we did a
lot of breakdancing competitions in the
80s around the bay area
and so when you go to break dance
competition we would we'd do our
routines but there were
some competitions that happened a lot
all over town
there were michael jackson competitions
and madonna competitions
meaning people would anyway people
dressed up like prince michael jackson
no one's dressing up as logan paul
bieber or logan paul
no one's dressed there's no there's no
personality where like
not even lady gaga like you don't see
people like dress up like lady gaga
they were full-on competitions of who's
doing the best michael jackson
with the whole thing and even if you
weren't in the competition you might
have had the
you probably won the jacket everyone
wanted that beaded jacket thriller
jacket
girls were walking around in lace lace
that's why they went to school
they're going to the mall in that's full
on madonna
madonna yeah like no one's doing that
icons anymore like this generation
we're not really creating icons
everybody wants to be their own person
but everyone's their own icon
which is healthy that's cool we all have
a voice now
instead of like the industry creating
icons now it's the people creating their
own icons because
they're like small icons i was yeah
because i think now
it's it's like it's more um customized
to like small groups or whatever right
instead of like
mega stars like like michael jackson the
whole world knows michael jackson and it
lasts for decades right you don't even
need to know pop or anything or
basketball like you don't even need to
know basketball you know who michael
jordan is
totally yeah you could be like in a
village
in thailand and if michael jackson was
still alive and he's like moonwalking
everyone be like
oh my god it's [ __ ] michael yeah you
know what i mean but like
we don't i don't know if we have that
today yeah but on the flip side it's
cool where that
awkward kid that sits in the room and
really loves
this particular anime yeah
and like feels like no one in the world
gets them and they like go online and
it's like oh [ __ ]
oh this is a little community that loves
this exact thing that i love and these
are my people yeah
that's true that's kind of cool back in
those days that person is just [ __ ]
true i mean they're like i don't like
michael jackson like just
a loser then you're done and no one
wants to talk to you sit in the corner
and
[ __ ] off the little elbows extra
dude i mean this show is exactly that
right like
we just wanted something different and
the media just sucked
but i feel like that's just now and
what's what's gonna be is
peop us people generated content well
yeah i mean that's what you guys did
with just kidding films with
creating your own skits your own comedy
skits to showcase like a different
perspective of
the asian american experience it was so
big i've talked about with you guys and
other cats like tim
and even like ryan higgin on them it's
like your generation did something that
our generation didn't do is like and
it's just because of big business there
was no asians on tv i was like i was one
of like
three or four asians you saw in the 80s
and 90s i could have said all the asians
back then
with fight with my hand all right we got
we got you we got bobby
yeah and before bobby we have what's her
name the girl
the the margaret cho john cho
john no but john cho is new though he's
my my generation no he's like he me and
him at the same time he came like right
after what did he do
he did uh harold and kumar's when i
first saw him
but that's our job billion of women bro
better luck tomorrow
barely like tomorrow yeah but he's still
a grown-ass dude already yeah he we're
about the same age
and then um but see i'm talking about
the night but the crazy thing is like
jamie chung was a little after yeah but
what you got but what happened online
with you guys
you know we're doing scripted characters
and you know the reality is cryptic
characters in hollywood
even characters we did 99 of them in the
history of hollywood is written by
white men like perspectives of asians or
black people
their perspective of who we are yeah
yeah it's filtered through the lens
what y'all did online it's just us being
people
yeah and that's like a it's like a whoa
hold on a second this is just
cats talking about what they think like
unfiltered
that doesn't fit any box in my mind of
how asians are supposed to act
when there's not really any rules but
you know that's i think the magic
yeah that was the cool part is everyone
representing themselves
and being able to tell our own story i
think that's why our community ate it up
or tell no story just be yeah just be
that was fun
yeah yeah
would you guys want to do that again
yeah i still want to yeah i mean i still
bring back skits and all that
i want to do like movies and stuff i
want to do something that's like
not so fast you know i think things like
tik tok and social media i think it's
really cool
um people really get to relate real
quickly but like some of my favorite
tick tocks that i'm
dying laughing for five minutes i don't
even remember what happened you know the
shelf life is
yeah so like i still i want to make
something that's like the equivalent of
like a painting where you can hang it on
the wall you can look like you know what
good fella
that's a film yeah if i'm going on
through cable anytime i see
[ __ ] goodfellas pop up i'm still like
oh should i watch it again yeah you
should watch it for the thousandth time
one more time but see the way that you
guys
are because you guys create these cool
sketches and cool funny things it's
about
it's about sewing those sketches
together and to make this film that you
know
it's gonna be a series of sketches
within a a big
a big idea which i think he has done
similar things in the past is just
the work and time to do that again yeah
that's true
i definitely want to though i don't know
if the
culture is feels as one anymore
like when we first did it i really
missed the back in the day
youtube asian stuff because it felt like
we had
it was like this like we had events that
we would all do shows together
um and then everyone kind of knew each
other and then now
they never started fighting no there was
no fights everyone was cool
like that but the thing is now we do
have a lot of
new creators that are asian but they're
like in the beauty space or
you know they might just be doing like
um rap battles or whatever
right it's just gamers whatever but it's
not
one group like it used to be uh and we
all kind of know each other
but we don't do the shows anymore we
don't do there's no community wasn't
that
i mean minus the no community part
because that does suck
but isn't it kind of cool though that
it's so many and like so
yeah that it's like so like oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah like it's done like
everyone's being represented and by so
many different in so many different
fields and by so many different faces to
the point where you don't
really know kind of not really like
there's a part of me that on us is so
dope
there's so many other creators and i see
like there's like a uh
there's like asian dudes in nfl now you
know it's just cool to see like all over
the
board people are being represented but
at the same time
um so like in terms of like
representation and media at least from
my perspective
it almost seems like white black
hispanic and asian right so we're like
fourth in line
to still see like let's say all black
film come
and in the amount of support that that
gets
when we have like an all asian like not
everyone was screaming about parasite
and that's the closest thing that we
have or maybe crazy rich asians
so for me i'm like if we're that far
behind we need to be that much louder
but for for us it's like i guess we've
reached to this point where we we are
kind of like a little bit better
represented
but arguably black people are way better
represented but they're still louder
so for so i'm like where's our support
in that in that regard you know true but
also i say
we have to make more because if you
think about the amount of like
black americans have made in hollywood's
like music
coming out all the time films coming out
television america
as asian that's why you guys have to
make more state more content because
it's like we the only way to even have a
shot to
to to make an impact is to make it you
know and that's all that's on all of us
individually
but for me i don't really think about
that part i'm thinking more about the um
the the what kind of community and like
like thing that we used to have
now it's just like small little groups
everywhere
and it's hella disjointed and then
there's just different groups doing
different things it's fine and all but
like i missed the
old school asian like thing and i feel
like
everybody that was watching to all
english-speaking asians all over the
world we went through the same
like thing like i was just in the czech
republic
and the the kids there grew up watching
our videos it's crazy and i was like
what the [ __ ] like this is just it's
kind of like that
small time mega icon thing right where
it's like
not a lot of people out there was doing
the comedy that we did
and then there was this shared
experience
yeah it's still there it's fascinating
but that's what i mean like you know
the amount of noise that obama gets
andrew gaine got like maybe one percent
of it yeah you know so i think for me
that's where like but age is too quiet
we need to make more noise maybe we
don't have to talk we just got to hit a
drum or something
that's where the unity counts you know
where it's like if we need to get behind
ourselves way more today's video is
brought to you by gabby
okay imagine just imagine
you could save 961 dollars
a year on car insurance like a bit tight
that would be pretty dang amazing that's
like 80 bucks a month i know right yeah
and actually with gabby this is super
possible
i had a check for myself because i was
like yeah right
this is another one of those aha you're
going to save money but then you end up
paying way more money
but i checked for myself and i was able
to compare and the transparency is
pretty awesome because they have major
providers it's not like these
insurance companies that you've never
heard of yeah
they got like what nationwide
progressive you know they have all these
different
major companies and what they do is it's
actually just a search engine where
you input all of your information and
it's a search engine
for insurance that's sick and then they
compare it for you
and they get the best rates and they can
tip they usually can't beat the rate
that you have like for me i was gonna
save around 30 to 40 bucks a month
so for me uh once i close escrow in
vegas for sure
i'm gonna use this service go to gabby
and see what the best home insurance
price is
for my home in vegas so this is
something that you guys are looking
forward to
you can go ahead and sign up there's no
obligation it's completely free
go to gabby.com off the record that's
g-a-b-i
dot off the record to just check to see
if you are paying
indeed the lowest rate possible that's
gabby.com
off the record thank you we know what's
really cool though is like seeing how
the asian community has banded together
a lot especially
recently i mean it's tragic but with the
recent asian attacks
like a lot of i've seen a lot of
creators on my feed like
speaking out and really banding together
so that's really tight
who who is the loudest asian out there
like
koreans i mean i'm talking specific
person like who do you think the loudest
asian not loud
loud like and how do you define loud too
like the biggest impact or actual
verbally verbal i mean impact's impact
is great but i'm talking like
a personality that you can get behind us
like that [ __ ] we're rolling
with that dude
[ __ ] that's hard a big voice because
we're not our culture's not really
into speaking it's more about that
saving face and being cool like that's
part of like universally about asians
like i think
who's the one that's like yo i think it
goes against
western like what works out here because
like taoism and zen buddhism and stuff
like that
it teaches you to go above that
and then the western consciousness is
they're at a different
level right now they're at a more let's
communicate let's fight
let's debate and then asian culture
is more like yo life is way bigger than
that yeah
so then but then it gets misinterpreted
as pacifism
weakness it's like mistaking kindness
for weakness right they don't
get what's happening because they just
don't think the same culturally
so then when we're like man you got to
be bigger than that that's
pointless don't waste your energy on
doing eye for an eye [ __ ] or whatever
you can't really get that support say if
there's a martin luther king or a
malcolm x
asian dude that's not like within our
yeah
jesus was like it was bruce lee like he
was our christmas bruce was
he's charismatic you know he wasn't he
he wasn't even verbally loud it's just
his aura was loud right
right i think you're right about that
it's like there's an inherent like
tendency
to not want to be loud and not want to
like someone's being that loud we're
like
don't [ __ ] with that dude who's this guy
blowing up the spot like this too
loud like relax bro you're only allowed
to be
loud when you're partying at a
restaurant or doing karaoke
karaoke but for friends like a guy like
tim right he's probably a good example
tim is probably loud he's one of the
guys that crosses over
like the the asian youtube space into
like for
like he's probably one of the only asian
guys that's on mtv
yeah well or not and like he has a
pretty big imp because i know randall
park was on it right
on wild now yeah but i don't think every
i don't think he's gotten the reception
that like tim has gotten when he's on
wall now because he's very popular he
has so many different tv shows on mtv he
has like five different shows it seems
like he transcends past the asian
community
he just like right and i think that's
really cool maybe one of the loudest
personalities in asian culture
yeah but it's also not like cringy where
it's like oh he's just always talking
about asian stuff all the time he's just
being him
and because he's just being him everyone
looks at him like a normal dude
but they're but he's an asian guy so
it's it's also really cool too but
he's probably one of the only guys i
could think of that is transcending that
we mean by loud
like because we got a lot of people that
scream and [ __ ]
that's true but not really and i just
want to be like
shut up yeah yeah yeah cause that's what
that's what i'm saying is like
like are you someone for me i was that's
what i was asking like how do you define
loud is it someone that
like made their own waves because
someone that's like that
is like lucy lou right she is way up
there but so much to the point she's by
herself
and never i've never seen her pull
anyone else up sandra oh yeah or or
is this is loud the people that make
waves
across the board for other people yeah
for other people like there are people
that have made it individually
that are like way up there but it
doesn't seem like they're part of their
community even
right i think i changed over the years
too
because i used to heavily identify with
my race to the point where i thought
that was who i was
so what um and i see this with the
younger generation too like when we're
trying to figure ourselves out you know
we're so
also being asian in america you're
trying to re you're trying to figure out
well i'm not white i'm not black
who am i right and then you're trying to
research who you are culturally and all
that stuff
and um i feel like the latinos don't go
as
much because it feels like there's so
much
if they're mexican whatever there's a
lot of mexican
culture in l.a yeah so like
like it feels like this is your home
right we're almost mexican
whether you're mexican or not if you
grew up in l.a you're half mexican
yeah but when you're but when you're
asian it's it's like you're in a
different world
and then you're trying to wrap around
like there is a huge contrast and if you
don't
think about it you don't know that if
your parents are new
immigrants asian immigrants or whatever
immigrant
that house that you're living in that's
like an embassy and you're growing up in
a different culture
yeah and then they're trying to make
sense of how to balance that out
with america and this culture right true
and then so like we're all we all have
to define what it means to be who we are
right and i think in that process
it's like i am a japanese american or
whatever people have this identity
but then once once you go past that you
go
wait i'm just a human being but you go
past that and you're like
i'm just nothing dude you code's
switching all over the place
joe just explained my whole childhood
you know yeah like yeah but but i i feel
like
that it can go dangerous when you when
you it's kind of like
saying this like if you're like i'm a
christian therefore
like i'm this right so when you when you
think about that
and you're pushing [ __ ] for asians and
whatever then it's like
i think you're doing yourself a
disservice by being so
limited in the human experience but
that's where i'm at right so i'm like
yeah i got love for the culture and all
that stuff but that's not really who i
am i think um i just have an experience
wholly who you are no it's just a part
of who you're but also
as a leader you know we've in our
successes in our lives and our careers
and stuff you become a leader in certain
things where you can help
uh broaden the voice of a certain
community
because if we don't do it then who we
can't leave it up to just white guys to
do it for us
like that doesn't move but doesn't that
doesn't necessarily
ultimately encompass all of who you are
it's just going i see there's a need
there for that
yeah so like i'm gonna open up something
a business for that
to amplify that but then it's like like
okay
for bruce lee for example right some
people see see him as this like
asian american leader whatever i just
see him
as this badass human being that
transcended
past his obstacles same with michael
jordan
same with michael jackson same with just
everyone
can be an inspiration to me but maybe
it's because
i went past that stage of feeling like i
have to
see other people that look like me to
give me confidence
it's normal though but i think that's
human nature right you need people of
your tribe to realize
oh [ __ ] it's not just uh
you may be black people that are great
at athletics like hey asians can
actually
be good too but it's just we didn't
focus that on that as a culture
but when you're when your mind is really
um like
i don't i don't want to say like small
because it sounds [ __ ] up but
really like you you believe the
stereotypes like
like i used to think oh asians can't get
buff because we're just genetically not
able to and then you go to the gym down
here and then there's hella buff asian
dude my parents didn't tell this thing
yeah but a lot we're not meant to be
strong you know what mommy used to say
she goes why are you stepping outside
the house with no sweater it would be
cold out
i'd be like what she's like you're not
like that white or black that's what my
mom's saying
you're not you're not like the white
kids or the black kids like our parents
will say that dude it's ingrained in
our own culture it's so crazy and like
loki like what joe was saying i was like
oh [ __ ] that used to happen to me
because
until i started hang out with david i
didn't really have that many asian
friends
like i didn't grow up with a lot of
asian people me neither he would say
things and i'll be like
oh [ __ ] like i guess that's an asian
thing or or something like that or like
you guys would say some things and i'd
be like
oh [ __ ] i used to do the same [ __ ] too
and what you're whole saying about
all that's that identity growing up of
like your house being an embassy and you
going outside
i was like oh [ __ ] that's so true so you
blew my mind right now joe
yeah but also like my parents weren't my
grandparents were immigrants so i was
third generation your parents were born
here guys don't speak they speak english
only and so it's a different experience
too where you're like
and we grew up in black and mexican
neighborhoods but the thing about
representations like now
through our careers and things that
we've done in this room and friends of
ours the door opens more and you know
you're
a bit part of it you kind of help open
it like now it's like
i just got called by a company to direct
a a film and a kids film you know
maybe like can you come and talk about
this kids from with a filipino star all
asian cast i'm like
that [ __ ] did not exist when i was in
this industry at the beginning
so it's like little by little what we
can do
is you know i'm saying like do you only
do what you can
yeah it's not your whole life but it's
like it needs to be done because then
and i'm sure you guys get it too you
guys go to colleges you eat fans in the
street and like how do i
how do i do what you're doing what what
i want people to do though
i don't know you're trying to you're
trying to figure out how can you do this
you know
let me figure this out because for me i
i think it's necessary
for humans to see someone that looks
like them
doing the same thing because we learned
by coffee depending on the human i don't
think it needed it you needed it i
didn't need it no no yeah that's what
i'm saying but then like
it's it's a part of confidence building
like for example when i was
like i said going back to thinking that
asians can't be athletic
that is a stereotype that i put upon
myself
no one really said it maybe the old
folks and they're [ __ ] stupid because
they make up [ __ ] in their mind all the
time
but like no white person told me that
asians can't be strong no one told me
that
but people are blaming white people for
certain things but i think that's also
wrong
sometimes you create things in your own
mind or sometimes
older people of your culture are telling
you stupid [ __ ] and you believe it
so there's many different ways how how
we frame a thought that's why it's
important to have representation where
we create
and we have these inspiring stories but
but i think it's very important to move
past that as fast as possible
we have to go like it's not just an
asian thing or it's not just
asian people that inspire me it's like
we gotta go beyond that and go
hey dude we all sharing this human
experience
and who can inspire to transcend past
whatever
what's the cra the crazy thing is like i
didn't we didn't really grow up a lot of
race in the house i mean we knew we're
filipino but kind of not really you know
what i'm saying
and so when you got to hollywood at 10 i
never thought about
any asian anything no part nothing
you're just here trying and i was a
breakdancer
everything was like a battle you break
dancing in the streets so every audition
was like a battle just
go in and win that's all we did and it
was
in a work for me through my whole young
career
but i think for a lot of people of color
like when was the moment that you
realized
you weren't white in america until i
started hanging out with him
what was that i was born into it my dad
was like the white man
white man like i was just like i was
born into that ideology
right so you thought you were white or
you think no no no like that that i
wasn't white and there's
something to measure up to you knew
innately just innately there's something
to measure up to and there's always like
a chip on your shoulder growing up and
that's just how i grew up
no i was in sixth grade and then
cerritos i was going to school at
cerritos in my neighborhood what school
you got in sixth grade
uh well i was at that time i was at uh
was it miller
georgie miller miller i'm fifth grade
it's fifth grade
because i'm a ted sloth i live in tesla
okay but so
my my neighbor behind me i was like
walking home from school steve myers
and he's white and there was something
that happened i was like
oh you're white i'm not
like it just was like an experience
where the first moment you found out
you're kind of a person to come like
fifth grade where i was like until then
it doesn't really matter he's just
friends
like you don't really think a race
genuinely lived my entire life up until
dating him
like you grew up in mexico i didn't oh
you were that you don't oh you grew up
in mexico no no no no no like paramount
downey
i had like asian friends black friends
white friends and
right but they're the majority it's
different people there was like 10 white
people yeah but i never noticed
it i feel like it's it's not necessarily
about growing up white or
asian or black or hispanic it's kind of
like
are you a majority or minority in the
area you grew up in
because i think the the the example a
tif is it's like
she's hispanic but she grew up as a
majority so she didn't
you didn't really i was not aware of
racial or
differences i i don't have enough of my
type in this area
and feeling like left out yeah that's
why not until i started dating you
and i was only around asians i was like
whoa
i've never felt this enough i was
reverse of yours because like my
experience was i was surrounded by
white people for most of my life and
then moving here and getting in with
jk i was like and now i'm surrounded by
asians and like being in monterey park
and i was like crazy this is [ __ ]
wild well going to paramount high being
so many mexicans would trip me out if
you watch tv right and there's like all
these roles
the classic girls the smart girls the
the cheerleaders the nerds
everything the tough guys tough girls
but they're all white on tv yeah
but in paramount they're all mexican
and you're like [ __ ] they never show
like that's the same one
yeah but they never showed the mexican
smart person and the mexican
cheerleader but it's like all there but
that's how you know like
tv's from a different filter that's not
really filtering and the same thing as
cerritos
it's like it's the same all the same
characters they're just all
multicultural or multiplayer then you're
going paramount it's just all meg it's
like you're watching
any tv show they're just mexican yeah
that's why
it never clicked to me that it was
different right i don't know
[Music]
you